un poco decoroso primer puesto para
América Latina el lugar de origen de más
de la mitad de los 57 periodistas
asesinados en lo corrido de 2022 según
reporteros Sin fronteras México Brasil y
Haití están a la cabeza en la región y
Ucrania Siria y yemen lo hacen en el
resto del mundo como lo Explica el jefe
Regional de la organización a France 24
vemos por ejemplo el caso de México que
es el cuarto año consecutivo en que es
el país del mundo más mortífero para los
trabajadores de medios También tenemos
el caso de Haití que ahí tenemos una
sorpresa no porque Haití en los años
anteriores no había casos de asesinatos
de periodistas o algunos casos puntuales
pero con todos los hechos de la crisis
política de seguridad pública que vive
el país los periodistas han sido blancos
sistemáticos los 500 Es 53 periodistas
en prisión también reflejan una cifra
nunca vista y las mujeres que hace
cuatro años se representaban el 11% del
total ahora ostentan un 15% las mujeres
están más presentes en el en el
periodismo o sea están cada vez más en
la primera línea de coberturas de temas
sensibles en países que están muy
marcados también por una una un machismo
estructural además de los trabajadores
de medios asesinados 49 han desaparecido
y otros 65 han sido secuestrados lo que
para reporteros Sin fronteras enmarca
una situación que calificó de
extremadamente inquietante